[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with politics editor at galden moyer
lothian and
lothian mclean forgotten your double
barrel name there and uh whitehall
editor for the financial times sebastian
payne so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the daily telegraph reports that police
officers who stand on duty in downing
street have been interviewed by sue gray
for her partygate investigation
the guardian leans on the prime minister
facing calls to open an investigation
after a conservative mp accused members
of her party of saying her being muslim
made others uncomfortable
the daily express also has that story
with an exclusive from transport
secretary grant shatz saying the prime
minister realizes there needs to be a
change in downing street
the metro leads on russia and ukraine
tensions quoting the ukrainian
ambassador to the uk
saying they will fight to the death if
russia invades the daily mail quotes a
top minister claiming that the whole
cabinet would back a delay to the
national insurance hike to help families
hit by the cost of living crisis
the daily mirror has examples of those
most affected by the cost of living
crisis
the times the financial times reports
that unilever is facing pressure from an
activist head hedge fund which is
building a stake in the company
and the sun reports that katie price
could be facing up to five years in
prison for allegedly breaching a
restraining order
joined tonight by moyalovian mclean and
sebastian payne
good to see you both thank you uh can
take us through the papers this evening
all the way through uh till uh midnight
let's um have a look at the guardian
front page and uh they're suggesting
that the the prime minister has been
pulled into this
tory rao they're describing it as over a
party islamophobia uh nazareth ghani the
claims that she's made
the prime minister did actually meet
with uh the minister as she was then
but is he still at fault sebastian
well i think what nusrat ghani said we
had a bit of backwards and forth today
on this story that she gave an interview
in the sunday times where she said that
after she was sacked as transport
minister in february 2020 and she had a
meeting with a whip who has now been
identified as the chief whipmark spencer
who and she alleged that he said her
that her muslim background was making
colleagues feel uncomfortable obviously
she was very distressed by this
allegation and late had a meeting with
boris johnson and down confirmed
nazareth had met with bob johnson and
boyce johnson wrote to her 10 days later
and said that there should be a party
investigation a tory party inquiry into
these comments or not ms ghani then
released a statement this afternoon
saying in fact this is not a party
matter this is a government matter this
is not for conservative hq's decide this
and she actually expressed her
disappointment that the government led
by prime minister boris johnson had not
taken this matter very seriously now we
should say mr mark spencer who is the
the chief whip has denied this it's
caterpillar not true he said it's
defamatory and false but it feels to me
if there's going to have to be some kind
of investigation because the comments
that miss ghani have made are very
precise and it's why you make something
up like that and on the other hand
you've got mark spencer saying the
complete opposite so someone is really
crying at the stick or not telling the
truth here and of course the whole
accusation has come at a time when the
whole government's under amount of
strain this is an epic week ahead for
boris johnson and his whole government
and it racism around i'm sure it's the
last thing the prime minister wanted so
i imagine in the next 24 hours who want
to act quite swiftly to try and deal
with this uh moya do you think that
swift action may come in the form of an
investigation
i mean it seems like the tory party are
drowning and inquires investigations at
the moment doesn't it uh
i believe at this point that it doesn't
seem like there's any other alternative
uh it would be coming straight off the
back of the sing inquiry which we had
the results of just last year which did
find that there was significant
anti-muslim sentiment within the tory
party at large uh but there will have to
be a sort of an inquiry focusing solely
on government process i think uh just
based off what um miss ghani has raised
yes the deputy prime minister dominic
raab has um
urged uh miss ghani to to make a formal
complaint to the party but as we're
saying she's not necessarily
sure that that is the the best route but
we've had other um cabinet ministers
come out and uh give their tuppence
worth haven't we survived him
yes that we saw sanji javid the health
secretary has come out to uh defend miss
ghani and say this should be thoroughly
investigated and nadeem sahar with the
education secretary and what's so
striking about mr jafford's comment is
that he came up after the downing street
statement here and that's why i think
it's inevitable there's going to have to
be some kind of investigation into this
because at the moment uh miss donnie's
made those
made those allegations and mr spencer
has denied them i don't think the tour
party would want to dispute this in a
court of law that would not go down well
at all so um it is a very damaging one
for the government and of course um
ethnic minority voters and particularly
muslim voters will see this and may add
to preconceptions they have about what
they feel about the conservative party
so the last general election 64 of the
of the bme community voted for labor
versus 19 for conservatives and the
conservatives have long struggled to
gain votes within the muslim communities
and when they see comments like that you
you know it speaks to i think this
perception the party hasn't dealt so
well with islamophobia and uh moy just
mentioned the singing inquiry which came
following a host of reports of activists
and and comments by and more senior
people in the party that were judged to
be islamophobic uh the thing concluded
that was not institutional um
islamophobia within the party but
highlighted big problems in the way it
was being dealt with in terms of the
complaint procedure and i think that's
again exactly what you're seeing with
nazrath ghani here that eddie you pass
this off to the party when it's a
serving government minister a chief whip
who's allegedly said this it needs to be
taken far more seriously
let's go back to the investigation that
we know is underway and we're hoping to
hear uh from that this week is that sue
grayson investigation
they have spoken to police officers at
downing street the daily telegraph tell
us moyer
yes so sue grey is apparently speaking
to all and sundry who may have any
information about this party and is not
just relying on the hearsay of people
civil servants and staff at downing
street but is checking things like
security passes apparently the prime
minister's diary and according to this
report from the telegraph
officers have been all too willing to
speak and that the material that's been
disclosed has apparently been
significant uh a source said put it this
way if boris johnson is still prime
minister by the end of the week i'd be
very surprised i think the main question
we have from this is if met officers do
have substantial information that will
change the outcome of this inquiry and
perhaps make boris johnson's position
untenable as reported by the telegraph
and are they if they are only too
willing to speak to grey what is that
information going to say and if it
incriminates downing street staff why
was it not acted upon earlier by
officers
well that's the thing sebastian isn't it
because it would implicate the officers
if if they didn't come forth with the
information prior to being asked about
it
well indeed and obviously the point that
thing's been made is that um those who
broke covert regulations um for the
first time were given one-off
on-the-spot fines of a hundred pounds
that then doubled on every subsequent um
um incident now obviously there could be
a question about why the police did not
do that i think the met would probably
say that in fact the police were there
you know to do diplomatic protection
they were not there as normal constables
enforcing the laws but it is a very good
question that if this was happening and
on the kind of industrial scale we've
seen reported with a party with over a
hundred people why was that not reported
their superiors and why was something
not done about it and of course you have
to ask a question that in some of the
parties that we've seen reports of there
was peace delivered did the police take
that pizza from the gate or did they
deliver it to the party itself so yes
i'm sure it wouldn't the tour surprised
me following the grey inquiry if there
was further inquiries into the police's
role in this whole incident but uh the
telegraph splash really is quite
bombastic stuff there that you know that
quote that boy just read out saying i'd
be surprised if boris johnson was
playing by the end of the week you know
this space that i see this inquiry being
is there about 50 50 at the moment from
boris and boris johnson getting
challenged in the next couple of days
that those less of no confidence have to
reach 54 to have that vote i think that
company about 30 but no one really knows
for certain and i think depending on
what comes out in the gray inquiry it
could be significantly higher and really
for the prime minister it's going to
come down to that crucial party in may
2020 which he personally attended and
has he been forthright and
straightforward about what he knew about
that and if miss gray who is a very
experienced civil servant has got a very
delicate balancing act to get through if
she concludes that he has not been
forthright and has not been honest with
parliament then i think it might not
even reach a confidence vote it may be
that the cabinet say to him look if
you've lied to parliament that's
normally a resigning matter under the
ministry or code so the next couple of
days in westminster politics are going
to be quite something uh very quickly
before we move on to ukraine did you say
that you'd be surprised if boris johnson
was there by the end of the week
well that was the quote in the telegraph
i'm not saying that sorry the telegraph
was uh quoting a police officer i know i
i thought you were adding i thought you
were adding your opinion this whole
thing is so volatile includes so many
different factors uh it would not be a
good idea to make any judgments or
predictions about where exactly it's
going to go very difficult to call let's
move on to ukraine in the financial
times and uh moya really the question
now is i mean is this
at the brink of war or can diplomacy
pull it right back
well to be honest with you i i've got no
idea it certainly seems uh as if we are
on a precipice and about to fall off
given that the uk came out yesterday uh
made a very strong statement about putin
uh attempting to install what they
called a puppet government uh in ukraine
now we've got the us we've got anthony
blinken calling uh russia's recent
actions to destabilize ukraine something
straight out of the russian playbook
which is certainly
uh drastic talk uh the us has also said
via blinken that um
there will be severe consequences if
russia does invade ukraine for a second
time but so far these consequences thus
discussed between european and other
western states such the us seem to be in
the form of sanctions which hasn't
deterred russia at all uh russia simply
does not want ukraine to join nato and
they will invade
uh and do anything to stop it basically
uh we've run out of time but uh hope to
pick up on ukraine we come back from the
break for the moment thank you coming
back uh we'll be talking about uh this
story in the daily telegraph the biggest
ever recruitment drive for magistrates
is being launched with everyone from
bricklayers to teachers being urged to
apply in an effort to increase diversity
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me the politics
editor at galden moyer lothian mclean
and whitehall editor for the financial
times sebastian payne um let's just pick
up with ukraine again sebastian and this
headline in the metro which is um
incredibly worrying a fight to the death
this is the ukrainian ambassador to the
uk uh an interview that he'd given to
trevor phillips on sunday and he was
absolutely adamant about what he was
saying
it was a very powerful interview
actually and i think it speaks to
the drasticness of the situation at the
moment that obviously the uk alleged
over the weekend that um
that russia was looking to stall a
puppet regime into ukraine and this was
quite rare for liz trust the foreign
secretary to come up with such a big
allegation and it's been backed up i
think on the front of the ft as well by
anthony blinken and the u.s secretary of
state who said they've been concerned
about this for quite a long time but it
is very clear that if vladimir putin
does invade and all the evidence
suggests that uh he is or he's very
serious about the threat then ukraine
will fight back and i think that's
exactly the front page as the metro
strikes there and i think it's all
incredibly worrying for everyone
involved and obviously those talks are
still continuing and the u.s and russia
have been in dialogue for quite some
time now to to try and avoid uh an
actual armed conflict but at the moment
that's not going anywhere and i think
everyone's watching to see what happens
after the beijing olympics which is seen
as potentially the most potent time but
the situation there is just very very
difficult you've just got to think about
all those people in ukraine and it's
very good to see the uk is on the front
line for this and is very much putting
as many resources in as possible to help
the poor ukrainian people who find
themselves facing a huge army with a vet
with an aggressor and who's got no
purpose for what he wants to try and do
there yeah very difficult situation and
uh the metro saying that putin has
warned of appropriate retaliatory
military technical measures unless a
list of demands are met including a
promise nato will never admit ukraine as
a member we know from that interview
that the uh ambassador was saying that
that's something that they would want to
consider so whether that can be a
condition um that nato will agree to is
highly unlikely
let's have a look at the mirror
and this story on the energy crisis and
it's actually um you know a human story
just talking about the the victims of
the the energy crisis
yes so this is the mirrors talked to two
pensioners uh diane skidmore
and jack mortimer who are currently
struggling with the rising costs of
energy
for example diane's story she's 71 years
old she lives in south london she
currently lives on 600 pounds a month
her energy bills have gone up by 50
percent she says she's always shivering
she says people who come to the flat are
always cold
and this is really a story about the
wider energy crisis that's going on uh
bills have already gone up by a
significant amount um and there's a
price cap changing in april which means
and estimates think that it will or it
will increase more by over 51
this is part of a wider
uh
rise in cost of living that they're
calling the big squeeze um and basically
it's it's a crisis in the making it's uh
stagnating wages plus the clover squeeze
plus the national insurance hike plus
these energy
energy bill rises and the removal of the
boost in universal credit just when it
was most needed and it is creating um a
reel of
hundreds and thousands of people we're
in real trouble right now there's a huge
pressure on the government to do
something asap to prevent hundreds and
thousands sliding further into poverty
but as of yet nothing has been announced
and the mirror in this particular
article are causing calling for uh vat
to be removed from these energy bills to
save costs yeah the mirror does do a
good job at uh really bringing the human
story to to the fore doesn't that
sebastian
it does and i think the uh the energy
crisis and the the general cost of
living crisis inflation bites is going
to be one of the big political stories
and i think of the coming months and
were it not for the situation ukraine
and the unstable political situation in
westminster that would be the top of
headlines and when you see stories like
the front page of the mirror and many
other papers there is a very clear human
cost there to what this is already
starting to bite in terms of food prices
in terms of energy prices i forgot to
mention with ukraine as well before that
uh if the west and brings in economic
sanctions which we've already talked
about doing um if
russia invades ukraine then they may
retaliate by and stifling gas supplies
and that again could make the situation
even worse i think it's the front page
of the times tomorrow has ministers have
been prepared for eye-watering rises in
gas prices if ukraine is invaded and
this spirals into economic sanctions on
top of each other so i think
fundamentally the government is probably
gonna have to do something whether it's
vat being knocked off energy bills which
if we recall during the 2016 referendum
one boris johnson advocated as something
we could do if we voted for brexit yet
curiously his government hasn't done
that the other thing which is on the
front page of the mail is the idea that
um the ni rise coming in april and to
pay for social care and the bat and the
covered backup on the nhs could be
delayed and the mail is saying there's a
majority cabinet support for that so i
think in the coming weeks the government
will do something from this menu of
options but in the meantime i think it's
clearly being felt out there